we are outside our studio here on west
57th street for a special outdoor
edition of dear drew
i love answering your letters our dear
drew segment is so important to me and i
am such a huge fan of real life mail so
when i heard that martha stewart had an
actual real mail truck
we knew we had to team up
so please welcome the legendary martha
stewart and friend of the show and of
course her real authentic mail track
don't you love it
i love it so much and this is authentic
oh no it's a real u.s mail truck and
every now and then when they get a
little too old i guess for the postman
they sell them off and i bought this
years ago for martha by mail which was
made a lot of sense and now
because we're all online shopping we did
we changed the name to martha.com that
yellow mailbox behind you is actually
mine you brought the mail truck i
brought the mailbox so cute
and
um we are so excited we're gonna get to
some letters martha the first thing that
we do in our dear drew segment is we
announced the zip code of the day and in
honor of you
it's
105 36 katona new york your beautiful
hometown
and it's also the hometown of our
station wcbs
cbs2
so it's home to colorful painted lady
victorians that were moved from the
original old town site in the 1890s
known second to none window shopping
every shop in eatery along katona avenue
is an independently owned or regional
business the katona chamber of commerce
hosts an annual chili cook-off every
winter
yum
and the prize is a golden ladle katona
new york you have the best neighbor ever
write to us we want to hear from you
and we are here with your greatest
representative well thank you for that i
i really appreciate pointing out the
good the good features of katona it is a
charming place i can wake up with my
chickens i can go to bed with my with my
horses and take them down to the stable
at late night check you know uh it's a
it's a very pleasant way to live um okay
let's open our first letter
dear drew i know you own chickens
and i just got chickens to raise in our
backyard
mimi fluff buttercup and mildred aka
millie and three of them are great but
millie never listens
how do you get your chickens to pay
attention
rachel boston spa new york well that's
nice well
i i would suggest that she pick up each
chicken every day and pet it just like a
pet and they'll get to be more and more
friendly i never thought i'd say this um
but i've now become also like addicted
to their eggs and an egg snob and i
don't want to eat anything but the
chicken you shouldn't you should only
eat your own chicken's eggs here's a hot
tip
tell me if i'm right about this
keep your eggs out of the refrigerator
and they will last longer
you do not have to refrigerate your
fresh eggs they stay grade aaa for a
week without refrigeration and then they
go down in a every week thereafter so
you don't really so you're going to use
your eggs within a week
and you can keep them out of the
refrigerator then they're warm room
temperature they cook up beautifully
thank you martha you're welcome and
thank you rachel we appreciate um your
can i read a little question um and um
martha i am very excited for you it is
your letter oh good
dear martha i love that you're such a
huge collector and curator of all things
amazing one of my favorite curations of
yours is your instagram page full of
amazing pictures
especially your thirst trap photos
any advice
on taking pictures like yours jasmine
morgantown west virginia
well jasmine
first of all if you want to do a really
good thirst trap just make sure you look
good
you have to look good and you have to
feel good and you have to be in the
moment and that one famous one the one i
took in my pool oh yeah my pool for i
had no idea what a thirst trap was when
i was taking that picture i was actually
trying to take a picture of the
beautiful planted
pot that was at the end of my pool and i
must have hit the reverse button you
know on my camera and there i am in the
picture i said boy you look really good
and i snapped it and that was that
i think that that is a very important
letter that we got because
what you said is such great advice to
people for their social media is you
have to be in the moment yes like don't
fake it don't do it no no none of my
pictures are faked
i just think that's such good advice for
everyone who feels the pressure and
never post an ugly picture or an
unfortunate picture of any of your
friends either always post nice pictures
of your friends then they'll post nice
pictures of you so then you always look
good and nobody knows that sometimes you
could look bad
wisdom from the hottie herself all right
martha says be in the moment i couldn't
agree more okay let's get to our next
letter this one comes from dolores in
branson missouri
i have a really cute cake stand um
that's just sitting on my counter all
the time i use it whenever i have the
time to bake which is not as often as
i'd like any other uses for cake stands
besides baked goods
dolores branson missouri well
apropos of cake stands
i collect cake stands and i have i must
have 500 cake stands
as a result i have come up with many
many many uses for cake stands not only
for cakes
but also for like a shrimp cocktail can
you imagine i do it at christmas time a
whole tear i start with a one this this
big and go up
and then we have these beautiful fire
king cake stands that are just going on
martha.com
so you can buy these and you can buy you
can stack them on top of each other like
this for a beautiful flower arrangement
these are dahlias freshly cut from my
garden and you stick these into the
little votive candle glasses and you
make a very pretty arrangement i
ordered
to stack them yeah you can do shrimp you
can do flowers a seafood tower yes of
your own on cake stands and fruit so
this beautiful this is also on
martha.com this beautiful white it looks
like an old iron stone i love this one
and these gorgeous fruits which you can
also get at martha.com by the way and
you have pairs over there from our
friends at
frog hollow farms in california
they they grow the best fruits have you
ever tasted their fruits i haven't oh
they grow apricots and plucots and pears
good right i'm going to take a bite of
the apple these are so good
so you can get um
more and more things we keep adding
beautiful product on martha.com so it's
all the kinds of stuff that i want and i
know you want and you can just go browse
around and every month we're adding more
and more products i have it's a new kind
of store good letter you get very good
letters
very good letters people respond to you
[Music]